de ses missions si la parole est à
monsieur jean louis costes merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre la santé
des affaires sociales
madame la ministre la situation en
matière de désertification médicale
aujourd'hui a atteint des limites qui ne
sont plus supportables
il y a urgence absolue les moyens
aujourd'hui sont considérablement
défaillant et la situation ne cesse de
s'en tirer d'autant que nous avons de
plus en plus vous le savez de population
âgée l'exemple de mon département de
lot-et-garonne est particulièrement
marquant nous avons perdu plus de 25% de
nos médecins entre 2006 et 2010 est la
situation ne fait qu'empirer
et si vous me permettrez de prendre
l'exemple de la sous-préfecture de ma
sous préfecture nous avons perdu là
aussi un quart et dans les territoires
ruraux s'est pratiquement 40% durant la
même période
alors aujourd'hui la situation est
devenue totalement intolérables les
patients ne trouve plus de généralistes
dans les salles d'attentes
les patients sont de plus en plus
agressif et la situation ne fait que se
tendre pire
bien évidemment les urgences sont
complètement encombré par des gens qui
devraient être traités par la médecine
de ville ou libérale est alors pour
compliquer les choses nous avons plus
maintenant des infirmiers qui ne sont
plus en capacité de poursuivre les
traitements dans la mesure où il n'y a
plus de prescription médicale derrière
alors je sais ce que vous allez me
répondre madame la ministre que votre
gouvernement les différents
gouvernements successifs ont mis en
place un certain nombre d'incitations
financières des incitations fiscales
un certain nombre de collectivités ont
mis en place des maisons de santé il y
en a un certain nombre
et pourtant ça ne marche pas et la
situation ne fait que se dégrader alors
je demande tout simplement madame la
ministre sur ce dossier
un peu de courage politique il est plus
qu urgent que nous légiférerons c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel de pouvoir
assurer à tournon administré une
équivalence de soins sur l'ensemble du
territoire
vraiment la situation est plus
qu'urgente ça me semble indispensable
merci
merci la pole est à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
cause du courage politique
je crois que nous n'avons pas manqué
pour faire face à ce débat et appelé les
médecins à assumer leurs responsabilités
dans les territoires ruraux dans les
territoires urbains en difficulté qui
eux aussi peuvent rencontrer des
complexités pour attirer les
professionnels et nous avons pris à bras
le corps or cette question en répondant
à un sujet comment faire en sorte de
créer des conditions de travail
d'exercice médical qui soit favorable à
la venue des jeunes ou moins jeunes mais
surtout des jeunes professionnels
nous avons répondu un certain nombre de
leurs demandes en déployant de façon
massive des maisons pluri
professionnelle de santé
il y en aura bientôt 1200 il y en avait
eu 170 en 2012 il y en a cent onze ans
nouvelle ac aquitaine 14 déjà dans votre
propre département en permettant à des
jeunes de bénéficier de bourses en
échange de leur installation dans des
territoires en difficulté 700 180
bourses ont été signés en nouvelles
aquitaine 1750 au niveau national en
créant de nouveaux contrats pour attirer
des jeunes médecins en échange d'un
certain nombre de facilités il y en a 50
ans nouvelle aquitaine 7 150 praticiens
de médecine générale au niveau national
et je pourrai ainsi multiplier les
exemples de dispositifs qui ont été
engagées il faut aller au delà
j'ai d'ores et déjà annoncé que 478
nouveaux postes seraient présentés pour
le numerus clausus et que le zonage des
zones en difficulté seraient revues dès
cette année mais monsieur le député
campagne présidentielle arrive et il
appartiendra à chacun de faire connaître
ses positions pour savoir si nous
prolongeons
mesures d'incitation ou si d'autres
mesures sont profonds